at a railway station just south of the
city of varanesh there's a small
military camp
the ground's all cut up a lot of kits
been moved through here recently
it's ended up at this much larger field
camp just down the road
seems to be a pretty big operation that
they've got going on here
and that we've driven right into the
middle of
the ukrainian border is about 170 miles
south
west the russian-backed separatist
republics in eastern ukraine
where there's been a pickup in fighting
in recent weeks a further south
still so it's strange to bring a lot of
troops here
there's always been a military base here
but it is massively expanded in the last
few weeks from the satellite imagery
there are more than 500 military
vehicles currently based here
from us just driving past it would
appear that there are
even more you can see how they've used
the uh
local facilities the local playground to
do their training exercises
just exercises is russia's stated
rationale for moving more troops into
crimea and to the border with ukraine
than at any time since 2014 at the
height of the ukrainian war
they're coming from far and wide across
russia from the 76 on these number
plates
you can tell these are troops from the
central military district
at least 700 miles further east
watering her plants at her dacha right
next door
nina says ukraine's president should
watch his steps
as germany's chancellor asked vladimir
putin to unwind his military buildup
russia says what it does on its soil is
its business
but has threatened the end of days if
kiev steps up what the kremlin calls
ukrainian aggression against the
separatist regions
where russia has now supplied passports
to more than four hundred thousand
people
[Music]
[Music]
so what's russia up to coercive
diplomacy or a prelude to war
if you want to start a war you you don't
warn everybody in advance you don't
waste
weeks in discussions moving troops and
stations
or like making statements and warnings
that's not
at least if that's not the kremlin style
of waging wars
if these are signals then they're hard
to read but what's clear is that russian
troops are ready
for whatever the kremlin plans diana
magnay sky news
near varonish russia